vous nous avez demandé comment peut-on
justifier le prix de la laitue iceberg
qui se vend en ce moment quatre dollars
et la laitue frisée 4 dollars 50
vous ne serez pas étonné d'apprendre que
cette augmentation est directement liée
à l éclosion d'infection à la bactérie e
coli dans la laitue romaine qui a créé
de très grosses pertes dans l'industrie
est bien sûr une certaine rareté comme
il s'agit d'un marché d'offre et de
demande
lille et du freeze et iceberg les
pousses d'épinards et autres verdures
ont quant à elles connu une forte
demande et par conséquent il y a eu une
explosion des prix la laitue romaine est
maintenant de retour en épicerie
l'identification de la région
problématique ainsi que les nouvelles
règles plus strictes dans l'importation
du produit devrait rassurer le
consommateur et pour vous convaincre
davantage les lectures humaines peuvent
se vendent aussi boc 1 $ 79 et pour les
autres les tuent les prix devrait se
rétablir graduellement